hey everybody its Carmel future here in
DC with a j+ i am streaming live
and um okay peace walk theme for this
year is change is coming
and a little bit I'll start marching
with a couple of people from other
organizations but I want to give you a
quick overview who's here so we've got
the answer coalition black ice matter
I'd say there's about a couple hundred
people maybe less exciting turnout the
last chair is told and again the theme
for this year as change is coming
again Washington DC
so much Jennifer Bryant right now
Jennifer tell me who you're with
I am go right to income organizer with
1dc warehousing and marching with
blacklivesmatter DMV and the answer
coalition awesome so this is this is not
your first time here no it's not this is
my second or third year coming to the
peach parade I live up the street where
actually marching through my
neighborhood so it's always great to be
out here on MLK Day so um let's talk to
you about this year in particular and
how relates to MLK his legacy given that
there's several debates from the
Republican side the Democratic side how
would you say that the the movement is
becoming politically well you know I
think when my friend Eugene spoke
earlier he really summed it up I think
the movement is shifting towards
embodying kind of the words of MLK
so we're not
and I hope that carries on where the
moment is 2016 Lord you saved us the
status of the way it is now is it
sustainable I think it's bigger than
just state violence our economy is not
sustainable for anyone really but
especially for my people Latino people
and people who are systemically kept at
the bottom and for anybody that's
watching it is freezing out here it is
well I think that's about 19 degrees
yes I think there's a couple of
questions popping up and I apologize
guys the sun is shining on the screen
but I like to talk to you more about
sort of the rhetoric that's being used
in politics at the moment
how would you how would a Martin Luther
King react do you think to the status of
politics today I mean when you look at
kind of the rise of almost fascism on
the right I think he'd be very opposed
to it I think he'd be very opposed to
just the the real lack of action around
creating a more equitable economy I
think he might be I don't know I think
that a lot of the issues that he was
fighting against still exist we looking
at poverty so I'm not sure how you would
feel about those politicians he might be
hopeful about someone like Bernie
Sanders who kind of at least in the way
that he speaks speaks to a lot of the
issues that MLK was about but I don't
know hmm
I've seen the hashtag reclaim okay used
a lot recently tell me a little bit more
about what that's about
well I think that when we talk about
reclaiming them okay we're talking about
reclaiming his radical legacy a lot of
his a lot of who he was has been
whitewashed and kind of watered down and
you see people on Twitter kind of
quoting MLK to try to silence activists
and quoting him okay in a way that's you
know that doesn't really speak to how
radical he was actually especially later
on in his life when he was speaking out
against the Vietnam War and when he was
speaking out against capitalism so I
think that we're reclaiming that legacy
going back to
I am okay and think about how it applies
to the movement work that we're doing
today because this is just a
continuation of good legacy awesome
thank you so much shut up her and I
linked up to the Buckeyes out of people
right now thank you
in reclaiming MLK's legacy often we talk
about little black boys and little white
boys hold hands
then it gets caught up in this
neoliberal dream of a post-racial
America and we're here to reclaim them
okay as a radical and say I'm okay
starting off that I have a dream speech
but we are here to cast a check because
black people were the original mortgage
of this country
State was bound on the genocide of
indigenous people and the enslavement of
black people you can't forget that and
you can't have liberal individual
individual individualistic solutions to
a collective punishment of people over
400 years
so we all want to fight like em okay did
against militarism racism and poverty
here to reclaim em okay is legacy whoa
jeez thank you
I'm okay thinks about the status of
American and how we progress that much
I think we've traded we've traded the
face of how oppression happens I think
you can't deny that some things have
changed I think some things have changed
but I think I think that that America
has gone with one vision of America's
dream how I was articulated very early
in his career and we've seen integration
was actually integration to a system
that we weren't meant to survive and so
one mile you might see more black faces
and black people for this is a power I
think the past has shown us that the
system is not actually equipped and
begins I think what we need because we
trained it into him Jim Crow from master
conservation we still have these
policemen tality innovates and black
people are still on the same position
the total hole that we were in in the
60s so I think it's been a mixed bag and
it shows that we need to actually
revolutionize the system and not merely
put more black faces in it would you say
that black lives matter of the movement
is caring for the legacy of Martin
Luther King jr.
I think that it's important when you
talk about what happened in the 60s to
make some important distinguishes
between the civil rights movement in the
Black Power movement and I think the
civil rights movement was based on the
idea that if we asserted our rights that
we could be part of the American dream I
think black lives matter is not
interested in being part of that
American Dream but actually
revolutionize if an amputated building
black power in order can have a dream of
liberation for all people so I think
ways in which the black lives matter
movement is a continuation of the civil
rights movement and there are ways in
which the black lives matter movement is
a continuation that Black Power movement
and then there are ways in which the
black lives matter movement he's doing
something different that's never been
done before
that's about living where we stand now
thank you all right thanks Erin we give
you guys undercook over either parade
there's a couple hundred people I'd say
it's the age ranges there's some kids
here all the way up to miss senior DC
again this is speed March Avenue in
Washington DC
change is coming as a theme just focus
on your last night's matter
all right thank you guys so much for
joining us hope you enjoyed it